so today we're going to talk about
excuse me one second
jeez
chronic phlegm in the back of your
throat
so to really figure this problem out you
want to think like an engineer
not as a medical professional because
when you do research on this you're
going to quickly find out
that it's all about again
suppressing the symptoms and even
classifying these conditions based on
their symptoms so it it makes this
symptom sound like a disease and
unfortunately they're not going deep
enough into
the root causes of these issues and then
also letting you know what are the more
common causes to
these symptoms so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to take one symptom chronic
mucus generation in your throat and just
trace it back to the most likely cause
now with this chronic mucus production
you can have a post nasal drip you can
have chronic coughing
more at night than during the day which
i'm going to cover why that is you can
definitely have hoarseness or a scratchy
throat you can also experience the
sensation like a lump in your throat or
something stuck in your throat you're
not sure what it is or even a sore
throat when you really don't have an
infection so to take an engineering
point of view they're going to look at a
cause and effect relationship they're
going to really
look at the logic behind this problem
instead of just taking this
tip of the iceberg symptom
and then matching a medication for it to
suppress it now you could have an
allergy you could have a virus in your
sinuses producing this mucus
but a more likely cause would be
something related to
two other symptoms which i'm going to
get to the root cause but one would be
gerd
which stands for gastroesophageal
reflux disease where you have
acid coming up through
this valve
at the top of the stomach and it's
coming up through your esophagus or this
other condition called lpr that stands
for laryngopharyngeal
reflux and so really the basic
difference between gerd okay and lpr
because they're both very similar the
valve is not closing and so we're
getting acid that comes up with gerd
into the esophagus but with lpr we're
getting acid that comes up higher into
the vocal cords into the back of the
throat and each one of these conditions
is classified as a certain condition
that's treated directly usually with
antacids and other medications that
suppress acid in your stomach now if you
have mucus in your throat you want to
ask yourself if you have
all these other symptoms that are
related to that so with gerd you would
have heartburn you would have
belching you would have regurgitation
you could have excess mucus throat
irritation you can have a lump in your
throat difficulty breathing because when
there's acid that comes up through your
throat your ability to get oxygen
dramatically decreases so you'll have
difficulty swallowing sometimes post
nasal drip with that and it's worse when
you're lying down at night because that
valve again is not closing correctly and
you may have food allergies which i'll
talk more about that and then with this
other condition called lpr you're going
to get a lot of those symptoms
but you also may have like a metallic
taste in your mouth and more irritation
in your vocal cords like hoarseness when
you're trying to talk now before i go
deeper into the root cause of these
issues i want to just talk first about
some of the treatments
which
can even cause the condition and
aggravate the condition even more for
example antacids a big side effect would
be constipation even acid reflux and
then you have these other medications
that are
work a little bit differently they're
called ppis
protein pump inhibitors so they
basically stop the enzymes that are
producing
um acid and they also have side effects
of
constipation gas
risk for stroke risk of getting c diff
which is an infection because it's a
pathogen palpitations and even high
blood pressure then you have another
side effect called
hypergastronemia now what is that that
is too much gastrin
which is going to cause too much acid in
your stomach so here you are trying to
get rid of your acid by taking
a solution that's giving you more acid
doesn't make sense at all another
problem with these treatments is that
they will remove acid and now you're
going to have a difficult time absorbing
minerals like calcium and magnesium so
now we have a problem with bones muscles
and the list goes on and on and on but
of course there's other solutions too
you can get a surgery you can tighten
this valve even more but there are some
slight minor complications like
inability to belch anymore or burp
increase gas in your digestive system a
greater need for more antacids and those
ppis that i just talked about so
ultimately
the optimum solution to something should
not give you a bigger problem
than you started out with right so let's
talk about the most likely cause of this
valve not closing
giving you
this gerd
or
lpr not too much acid it would be
an acid deficiency low hydrochloric acid
when the acid or concentration of acid
in your stomach is lower
the valve um doesn't close that properly
in fact it can open up but when the acid
starts increasing when you start
digesting things like proteins
the top of the valve should close very
very nice and tight if everything is
working correctly so the root cause of
this valve not closing is basically you
don't have enough acid in your stomach
and that is the underlying reason and
because you have acid reflux you're
thinking wow i have too much acid i need
to get rid of this acid so i'll take an
antacid or or i will do something to
reduce the acid but the root cause is
actually you don't have enough acid now
hydrochloric acid in your stomach is a
very
important
fluid um for many different things
especially within your immune system
one of the purposes of this very strong
acid which should be between one and
three
is to kill pathogens believe it or not
your stomach is very sterile okay
nothing can live because that acid is so
strong and this is one of the barriers
that your body puts up in the immune
system because if we can kill pathogens
that come from our food into the stomach
and prevent them from going down to the
rest of the tract we have a very good
defense against these pathogens
but if we have weak acid in the stomach
pathogens can escape and get into the
system and create all sorts of problems
in the lower part of the digestive
system and even in the small intestine
you can get what's called small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth and that
occurs because you didn't kill the
microbes at the stomach level
another very important purpose of this
hydrochloric acid is to break down
proteins to break down proteins
fully okay so if you don't have enough
acid in your stomach you'll get
incomplete
protein digestion and start to create
stress in the other parts of the
digestive system because they have to
produce more enzymes and they have to do
different things lower in the tract and
that throws off your whole digestion now
if you compound this with inflammation
okay in the gut and you have something
called leaky gut syndrome these proteins
go right into the little holes where you
have leaky gut and your immune system
starts creating antibodies against these
proteins and that's the start of
autoimmune diseases that's the start of
an allergy and then the third reason why
we need this hydrochloric acid in our
stomach is in your ability to absorb
minerals okay
so without that ph the minerals don't
travel into the body that well
so this is one of the underlying reasons
why people are anemic or they have
mineral deficiencies they cannot absorb
minerals calcium magnesium potassium
zinc
iodine all these minerals but also this
strong ph
triggers things in your pancreas to
release certain enzymes as well as in
your gallbladder to release bile so
without this
concentrated
hydrochloric acid in the stomach
being at what ph should be
for the entire digestive system
starts to go downhill real fast and on
top of everything else
the sensing mechanism doesn't allow that
that valve to close tightly
and then the acid starts regurgitating
you may even get regurgitation of the
bile up into the stomach
and both hydrochloric acid and bile can
then regurgitate up through the
esophagus up into your throat and this
irritates the back of the throat and
puts you in a constant state of
mucous protection that mucus is trying
to be formed an attempt to protect
against the strong acid that is
dissolving
your tissues so what i'm talking about
is the most likely root cause
of this mucous production this chronic
irritation your throat that makes you
cough so now that we know that the
solution is very simple because we don't
want to necessarily suppress the symptom
we want to fix the root cause we want to
now increase the amount of acid in the
stomach and by the way you're going to
have to figure out with help of your
doctor
how you can start to wean off some of
these antacids and if you're not
interested just ask them this one
question what are the
long-term effects
what are the chronic effects of taking
antacids over a period of time and
what's really behind these problems and
um you know i'm sure you'll be curious
to find out what they say but it'll
probably be something along the lines of
well it's just stress it's just genetics
and as we age most people just have
these problems but the way to get your
acid back
is to take um something to start
building up the hydrochloric acid and
the best remedy is betaine hydrochloride
okay betaine hydrochloride and you'd
want to take between
three to four to even five to six even
seven
right before you eat okay so that's what
i would recommend now here's the problem
with certain types of people that take
this if you have
an ulcer
because this condition has gone on too
far or if you have gastritis there's
inflammation in the stomach and you take
betaine hydrochloride it's going to make
it worse because the tissues are
inflamed in which case
you're going to have to heal
the lining of your stomach first which
could take anywhere between two to three
months okay before you start adding more
acid to the system but you need to
understand the mechanism here you need
to know that ultimately you want to
acidify the stomach and get it back to
normal so if that is the case and you
have an ulcer or you have gastritis
you can watch that video i will put that
link down below you could probably
benefit greatly by taking zinc carnosine
if you don't have an ulcer taking
betaine hydrochloride can greatly
greatly help you
in addition to that there's other things
you need to do because
the foods that you're eating probably
are not helping you and the biggest
offender for this problem
is
grains okay grains now what's wild is
that if you look this up
they will tell you to consume grains
to improve your acid reflux but in
reality you're going to find that makes
a lot worse there's a lot of things in
grains
that are inflammatory
okay that create sensitivity allergies
autoimmune conditions even lower your
immune system
and dump a lot of omega-6 fatty acids
into the system a typical grain has like
20 or more times the omega-6 than it
does the omega-3 which are
anti-inflammatory so you're basically
dumping a lot of inflammation in your
system when you consume grains and
consume animal products that were fed a
lot of heavy grains
versus grass-fed brass finished animal
products so i'm just trying to get you
to think with this and think outside the
box and see if you can start to sort out
your own diet and what you need to
change now
it's essential also to do intermittent
fasting and not follow the well just
have uh
five or six small meals through the day
no no no you don't want to do that you
want to do intermittent fasting because
the more that you do intermittent
fasting when you fast a period of time
at least 16 17 18 hours by skipping your
breakfast
you can now give your digestive system a
chance to rest and heal and recover
because it's not constantly being
triggered by foods
now another big cause of this entire
problem and i'm talking about low
stomach acids
and
a lack of
bile salts okay which can inhibit your
ability to digest
fats
is a vegan diet okay
when someone's a vegan many times
they consume a lot of grains
and a lot of foods that tear up their
digestive system
and they don't consume a lot of animal
fats and because they're not consuming a
lot of animal proteins
they might not have the triggering of
this hydrochloric acid so the
combination of all these inflammatory
foods and also the missing nutrients
that are in a vegan
diet can create havoc on your digestive
system now that being said there is a
correct way to do a vegan diet so i'm
not opposed of doing it correctly but i
am opposed to doing it with all the
different fake meats and the soy protein
isolates and the grains and the sugar
etc etc now i hope there are some good
takeaways from this video but i think
the next most important video for you to
watch would be on hydrochloric acid
check it out i put it right here
you